welcome back to new rock stars one
vision episode seven just subverted our
expectations
yet again well by giving us pretty much
what we expected
spoiler warning for episode seven if
you're just joining us now but agnes is
agatha harkness it was
agatha all along i'm eric boss here with
jessica clements
are you still feeling good jessica yeah
um eyelashes are still
on i drank a red bull everybody this is
a bonus bite-sized episode 7 q
a that we are doing with our listeners
on stereo we are recording this live the
morning of
the episode drop and you can join us for
future weeks by downloading the stereo
for free
at stereo.com new rockstars let's take
our first question
here do you think
that wanda is on nexus because we saw
her take
some sort of medication oh let's talk
about
that that's such a good question that's
not even a question that's a good fact
we got this nexus commercial that
basically means that
uh wanda maximoff as we know from the
comics is a nexus being she has control
over uh lots of different reality resets
and she's not confined to or bound to
any one particular
reality and in the comics you know
characters like jean grey
kang the conqueror franklin richards
they they're all kind of
able to switch around to different
realities and i think we're going to
learn more about this in loki but
as our stereo listener just pointed out
yeah we did see wanda taking some pills
in that scene and i think the
implication is those were the nexus
antidepressants
i guess the question is what does that
mean in the rules of the broader world
within the reality i think she was just
using it as an antidepressant
um but is this uh you know is this
really a pill given
to her by agatha maybe to uh you know
kind of like that plant that i talked
about
the uh yeah wonder ever bloom and it's
been
put in this medicinal form to allow
wanda to continue to see this the spell
it helps completely at bay oh my god
yeah completely
especially and that is the nexus pills i
think because the nexus bottle
was red that she was taking the pills
out of but it was also the branding is
also red so she definitely was taking
those pills it's definitely administered
because of uh
um agatha that's 100 i completely agree
with that
um i don't think she's taking them to
the nexus because i don't think you can
take people to the
realities in between realities
but i think those pills are the like
flower
or essentially something that she
created that makes her
powers either stronger weakens her
senses does something that's just like
oh that was a good fact oh my god that
person
it was a great uh observation there and
i think
what we're seeing now in one division is
that um this hex
the way it expands and the way wanda
uses it is gonna be the origins of the
multiverse and the mcu yeah
and i think she already is a nexus being
she just doesn't realize that yet
yeah and then and i think agatha
underestimates that
um like i don't know if agatha knows
that wanda is a nexus being
that um maybe you think so
okay well maybe that's part of this plan
right is she's trying to
use uh wanda as a nexus being or i don't
but i still don't think she fully
understands or appreciates how powerful
wanda can be
maybe she's trying to enlist wanda and
that's the like
good part of good part i'm putting
quotes around it because she's not good
but like
the good parts of um agatha maybe she's
trying to enlist wanda to be like
our powers combined do you know what
they would do
we could literally take over the
universe if we work together and she's
going to be like
i just want to bring my husband back i
just want to bring you back
leave your husband i you know yeah just
be the old
neighbors who grow all together and play
with their cats
and that's a perfectly fine way to learn
and kill every dog i guess because
in our gardens that digs in our gardens
and eats our drugs
um no i completely agree with that i
didn't even think about that which is
this is why
we need stereo because i didn't even
think about i i think about everything
else
but that was a good fact let's take
another question from stereo here
okay so do you think that agatha is
from the main universe or do you think
that she is from hell or
wherever mephisto will be due to the
fact she knew
about evan peters not pieces
so i could see either being the case
here's the deal
um with agatha's basement
the aspect ratio changed right to make
it seem like this was part of the main
reality as it is outside west view so
based on that cinematic
trope those are the kind of the rules
the language that wanda vision has set
i think that basement is set in the real
world of the mcu
and i think that this agatha existed
in this world but here's the other
caveat problem with that is a sword
wasn't able to identify her
her um photo driver's license and i
think that's kind of the
argument against that you know maybe she
is from just another dimension and
they're like we don't know who this
woman is and we don't have any record of
her existing
um i just think she's a very very old
witch who has now lived off the grid and
she's used sorcery to be able to survive
and live off the grid and she's been in
the mcu
but i think her magic her sorcery um
and maybe her use of wanda as a nexus
bean
allowed her to peer into other realities
and maybe
it's kind of a meta wink to us to the
fans the watchers
uh and to maybe to the real watcher
jeffrey wright the watcher of what if
uh that this evan peters is just a
different guy from a different reality
and i don't think that necessarily means
we're gonna have a concrete bridge
where uh professor x can wheel over it
to get to him
that'd be sick it would be sick it sucks
i mean
mcallen so freaking good i'm just bummed
i you know it's gonna be hard to replace
them but if anybody can do it it's
kind of spiky yeah and then also i'm
down to take those roles i am of age
i am of age and a veg i'm of age and
likeness
let's get jessica in the mcu you'd be so
great
jessica has magneto i would only want to
play a villain i love the villain
oh the gorilla the corella movie but
let's keep going sorry
this is one division oh yeah let's let's
take another question
why was the mailman smiling
when agatha took wonder away
this mailman there's something with the
mailman they're wrapping up with the
you think the mailmen okay do it talk
about it we need to see
jessica i read it as he was just going
back into
17 same well okay so
okay okay okay there's been two
different times where the mailman had
too
clear of a presence that didn't need to
be there so that's why i'm like
and we haven't talked about or we talked
about it but we haven't touched on it in
one division yet
like the scene with the guns the scene
where he's like your mom will be able to
find him no matter what i was like
these parts why does he get such big
lines and it's not like the guy with the
mustache where it was like comic relief
these are lines that are like specific
for some reason
and then and this one i was like oh
they're just flashing back to dottie to
him to be like
everyone in the neighborhood is watching
this but again i was like
there was two other times where this man
didn't need
a full sentence and they made it very
specific
and like gave him like a a huge platform
everything was silent everything was
there he was spotlighted
so what who is he if he is just a
mailman i'm gonna be very upset because
i might be reading too much into this
but it now i know how you feel but he's
something he is something he has to ah
well here's
here's my theory did he see his delivery
service name it said presto
it was a rabbit oh on this one on the
wait this one this episode
this episode this episode the mailman's
delivery service it was like a
it was not a usps it was like a uh ups
fedex kind of thing it was called presto
and it was a rabbit i'm sorry so he
could be tied with agatha
professor oh mr senor scratchy um
i mean you know it's interesting there's
a pixar short my favorite pixar short
called presto where it was a rabbit that
was that was the name of the rabbit who
was pulled out of a hat
and uh gets in this battle with the
magician who's like a real life sorcerer
on the stage
and he just wants to carry it i don't
think it's a pixar reference uh
okay okay can it be a pixar reference my
fiance can't kill him
kelly it's like i have to get her
permission if i bring up pixar yeah i
and i totally wrote that part off
because
what i didn't think about it hey it's
okay it's okay well i'll discover it i'm
gonna beat myself up
someone on twitter was like boss called
this out and i was like yeah and i'm
kicking myself about it
i'm trying to catch it i did well the
only reason i wrote it off was because
the last episode with him
i was like i zoomed in on his name and
it just said like delivery
so i was like oh it just says delivery
it just says his
shirt's gonna say delivered here
yeah and so i was like so when i saw him
in a different outfit i was like oh he's
just still a mailman
didn't zoom in didn't zoom in oh
god i'm so mad i'm so early let's take
another question from stereo
do you think agatha is behind the
impedance to vision and darcy
yeah uh yeah the ones that came in the
the roadblock
the traffic light i think she was the
one who's trying to delay
darcy and vision from getting back uh
because i think she knew that vision was
getting
outside of the reality um when
that's that was her goal to get him out
of there last episode and then now she
knows that one when wanda expanded that
vision's back in it
so she's trying to set up all these
roadblocks to keep vision from getting
back to help uh
to help wanda and just like that he went
off the grid for a minute y'all
y'all not on stereo and he came back
full force
nothing stopped boss nothing stops
ever uh all right let's take another
question from stereo here
is ghost writer gonna be brought into
the world of mine
because
which is how i always feel um yeah
uh yeah we got to get in on this oh yeah
oh yeah this is
yeah ghost rider will be coming to the
mcu
um i don't think in wanavision i think
it's way too soon
to bring a ghost he just rides in on
that motorcycle
i would hate that oh god it would be
too wild the only way it would make
sense jessica is if this ends with some
pandora's box of every marvel demon just
like
jumping out like wee another end game
portals moment but instead it's just all
the [ __ ] from hell
yeah so i would oh that'd be so sick it
was just like all the way
ghost rider type like demons coming out
that'd be kind of sick i'd be okay i'd
be into that i'd be into that
but this is why i want mephisto because
mephisto is the one who gives
ghostwriters hellfire right so like yeah
if you get mephisto in there a lot of
fun realistically
mephisto would bring the fun mephisto
would bring more people which is fun
nightmare would just bring the
chaoticness of nightmare which is fun to
me
i think right which we wouldn't get into
it but i am obsessed with club fear
so i was like if this mother like he's
basically oogie boogie from the
powerpuff girls and just imagine like
like kim coming in and it'd be so fun
but i am like mephisto would bring more
characters that would be greater for the
mcu whereas nightmare would just bring
his cool chaotic energy which
freddy krueger's great and all but like
i want to see more
demons let's take another question
we got another brief view of dottie
what's up with that
nothing i think nothing's up no i'm just
kidding
i think she's just guarding no she might
be part of a coven i mean marina had a
great theory on white theory this past
week about how
uh agnes goal is to kind of reassemble
her her cover
and that a lot of those women in that
women's group including dottie could be
members of this uh of this country i
think i'd love it if dottie were also a
witch like just another witch
and so is twitter
yes you can i want to be in the same
believe you right
oh okay i want to be accused by
young little girls just who didn't like
my food oh yeah let me be winona writer
let me be winona writer
um in the crucible uh but yeah
yeah that makes sense and also why she
wouldn't put herself as the leader of
the group
so it's not too weird because i was like
why would dottie be the leader of the
committee than if she was
the one of the witches but get there off
the trail
that's the rule for committees whether
it's like a study group or some kind of
committee you're in your drama club
you don't want to be the leader of it
you just want to be someone on net
you want a seat at the table and the
room you just want to make the funny
jokes in the back
and the details doubles in the details
while you drink
quietly from your flats second other
question
considering that agatha's powers look
very similar
to wandas and ax similar
do you think that she also have has her
powers derived from an infinity stone
um no i don't think so only because i
think that's going to be
what gives wanda the edge um i think
agatha's power
is ancient and is comes from like
eldritch magic
um or some other kind of magic that mc
mcu's about to establish
via the dark hold but i think the fact
that wanda's power
is a mix of that plus cosmic radiation
from the infinity stones is what is
going to allow her to overcome agatha by
the end of this
it's what gives her access to the
multiverse what's what makes her a nexus
being
uh so but ultimately i think other than
wanda's history i hope the mcu moves on
from the goddamn infinity stones
i'm i'm ready i think there i think with
the dark hole that that's what they're
doing with the
hole i i completely was like oh thank
god i think they're completely like
we're done talking about it unless the
flashback we're on the dark hole now the
dark hold is the new
gauntlet thank you to warby parker for
sponsoring this video
so warby parker is committed to
providing exceptional vision care online
and in stores
offering eyeglasses sunglasses eye exams
and contact lenses
glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses
sunglasses progressives and blue light
lenses are also available but if you
need help choosing frames here's what
you do you take their online quiz and
they'll suggest some great looking
glasses that are totally personalized to
fit your face and your style
i took the quiz and i got my free home
try on kit for sunglasses i love getting
a box full of cool sunglasses shipped
right to me
try on and see what i like and see what
fits my head the best so i need you guys
to help me out i gave you a hop on a
zoom call with someone whose taste i
trust to ask what they think and then i
just ship back all the ones i don't want
for free
so what do you guys think we got this
one this is the
maddox we got the barkley
there's the fletcher they have a little
white stripe in there
these are all wide because my head is
freaking huge
that's why warby parker's so great does
they give you the option
they're not like a giant who's trying on
baby glasses these are the barkley
large the frame's a bit thicker bit
sturdier
and these are the landy whiskey tortoise
which just sounds like a drunk turtle
yeah so which of these five do you guys
like let me know in the comments i kind
of want your feedback
your opinions mean everything to me so
warby parker sunglasses feature premium
polarized lenses that are scratch
resistant and provide 100
uv protection and you can get these with
prescription lenses so try worry
parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try at
home for free for five days
there's no obligation to buy it ships
free and includes a prepaid return
shipping label
try five pairs of glasses at home for
free at warbyparker.com
new rockstars all right let's take
another question
what's your favorite witch or wizard
from any
fantasy or fiction or ip oh that's a
cute question oh
breaking out of wanda now um let's see
favorite
oh witcher wizard oh i was just thinking
about this
i mean i just watched wizard of oz i
love the classic margaret hamilton which
i think she's so great
uh i love the practical magic she does
because here's the deal i love it movies
and tv show where the people
actually have to know how to do some
sleight of hand stuff in order to be
witches and wizards
uh harry potter and the cursed child if
you watch that play all the actors on
stage have to do sleight of hand stuff
it's really freaking cool the story's
stupid but the
performance of it's really cool um and
if you watch the original wizard of oz
uh margaret hamilton has to like climb
out of a hole you know
and sink down in a hole at one point she
like mixes she like gets a mortar and
pestle
and then it has incense that rises out
of it like she had no timing in sleight
of hand
so while there are other cooler like in
lore witches and wizards that exist
right now i'm going to go back to wizard
of oz margaret hamilton i freaking love
what she did in that movie
i don't know other than like you know
the ultimate
witch from halloweentown um
halloweentown that's a disney deep cut
um you know other than
my my baby my baby girl in halloweentown
i don't know that's such a hard question
because it's like i'm a person
i'm a big fan about rainbow movies does
raven count as a sorcerer
i have a right up here i have a raven
doll i should have said it's the future
that makes sense raven raven raven
should be in our top five sorcerers
of course i'm talking about that so
raven what else would i be talking about
no i'm not talking about teen titans
that's a different superhero universe
come on i'm staying in disney okay and
so oh okay i'd like to say marbles
like this oh so you're talking about
raven simone
we've got some more i thought
why would i have a that's a raven doll
here that's what i wanted they're like
wow you're a huge fan
well our buddy erica wussu wrote on the
reboot of that so raven so it's like
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe you can get a book
for it yeah oh my god you said a raven
samoan
i said i'm a big fan of a [ __ ] and you
said that's a raven i said
that show's terrifying it's terrifying
she can see
the future i hate you if you can see the
future you're just
insane thriller and it's because you're
a wizard
you're a wizard raven and she goes
i'm so i hate you so much all right
let's take another question
i mean mephisto first appeared as a fly
in the comics
that could have something to do with it
but i don't want to feed into eric's
theories anymore but
they said i have to because you're
putting them in a chokehold
i hope he's watching this now and sees
that you're ridiculous
i don't think that fly was mephisto i
think that fly
was a reference to like oh this is a
witch who has like all kinds of weird
animals and cool including cicadas and i
think it was the silence of the lamb's
thing
personally i think it definitely wasn't
a it was it was too big to be a fly
that's why i was like this is a cicada
um yeah this is a sucker cicada two
pixels um it's also very loud it's too
it's too loud for a fly but just loud
enough for a cicada
if you guys know skaters they're
annoying and i hate them um and i hate
them
well and uh a thing they stay cocooned
what they have like 17 years where they
don't
like they just stay asleep and then they
have a show yeah they and then they come
reproduction cycle
so that could be like you know how agnes
stays like dormant dormant doorman kind
of like the way pennywise in
it stay dry oh yeah or like jeepers
creepers she's just a
monster that comes back every spring
after ten years
um but yeah no i think that'd be cool
though and also you don't have to feed
into
bosses weird yeah i'll find it i'll find
my feed
i i'm a natural grazer of theories i
don't need to be
hand-fed my theory i like that they
ended it was like
i i have to or else it'll kill me
all right another question what do you
think would happen
if vision touched quicksilver's temples
like he did
to um darcy and
the other character i forget who it is
oh um
norm abby lash uh yeah i don't
think anything well quicksilver might
run too fast to be able to cut he's a
little slippery fella um
but quick quick if he were able to tap
him i don't think anything will happen i
don't think
this pietro has like a real world
counterpart because i think this evan
peters cameo is just kind of it's a wink
to fans it was a
it was a whatever something being
puppeted by um
agnes agatha and i don't think they're
gonna let evan peters live on as just
like a west view new jersey resident
i think fans would be like well then why
did you cast him i think it's it's a
he's a bit of magic
and when you try to read the mind of a
blob of magic
i think he would just like stare at you
and be like what are you doing
in my face like that moment where he did
it to agatha i think that was clearly an
act what she did there did you drop
something oh yeah it was an act
yeah you were so shocked by it being an
act like what
um i think it i think yeah it was
clearly an act
and then when the sun was like i like it
here because it's quiet
you're quiet agnes you're literally
nothing on the inside basically
you're enough i think the same thing you
are nothing you are trash
who are you the kid read her to filth
so i think that um the same thing would
happen if they touched the temples or
whatever he zip zaps up um
i drank two red bulls okay calm down
this is 201.
so i think the same thing would have
happened where it would just be like
nothingness
and just like uh he'd be like you
thought you could do this to me i'm not
existent
you're dead and i'm non-existent baby
yeah i think that's what it would be
all right let's take another question
hey i don't know if anyone has asked
this already but what do you think that
plan is that hayward is about to launch
um right before um
monica went back into the heads you know
what that is
yeah i think he's to just bomb the [ __ ]
out of it personally i think
the guy doesn't have any other levers
yeah
oh you think he'd nuke it like wore the
world's it i don't think he
i don't know i feel like there's still
pieces that we don't know maybe he's
found out like
what actually breaks the hex a little
bit more just how like wanda was like
i need to build this machine this
machine will go through the the hex i
think he's
doing the same thing but just like how
can we destroy it all but
he might try to nuke the city just to
get rid of it and take it off the map
and be like we're done with it we're
done with everyone there
which would make more things for him
believable because he's already bad so
he's just trying to kill everyone that's
already there
i know more radiation right that's it oh
yeah what oh
mixing a lot of radiation in there yeah
um let's take another question
total random theory question but if
nightcrawler was in the mcu
could he phase into the hex
and be himself
the rules of kurtz wagner means he has
to see where he is trying to go
so he'd have to see inside that hex
uh occur you know and currently uh
you can't really see it through that
wall i bet he could though
i bet he could but if you're watching
one division could you jump into one
division
into the tv show yeah he just smashes
the tv set when he goes inside
i bet he could i bet he could yeah um
but i feel like wanda would still mess
with him like he could still be messed
with he might not objectively
impenetrable
right yeah or i could imagine like you
know if kurt wagner existed out there he
might be like i cannot
uh for whatever reason it's not letting
me and he's
yeah her song for whatever oh got it so
he's doing documentaries now
yeah oh god i gotta get it i got it the
depth of the sword knows no
power please you stop except one that
one is willing to explore anyway let's
move on yeah
hey eric where's our mephisto shirts
we're trying to make you money man i
need
i am mephisto or where is my fisto
t-shirt
let's make you some money is this
phillip
yeah it would not make me a dime but
uh go for it uh tweet phillip about this
incessantly until he does it because
uh he's the one who controls what shirts
we do um
get a mephisto and agatha sure yeah
let's do it he's the one that's in
control of the t-shirts tweeda phillip
there was an idea brought up um i think
nerdy drew from
uh our discord uh world's pitched
something like it should be like uh i
was wrong boss is wrong about mephisto
or mephis no or something like that
uh if i end up eating no
all right we're gonna take just a few
more questions here do you think
when all of the people of west view were
saying
she's in my head do you think they were
talking about
agnes or i guess agatha instead of wanda
yeah i think this latest episode uh
makes a good case that it was
agatha in their head because norm is
like yeah get her out of my head
uh she's in my head this is her you have
to stop her
and i think the her now maybe he wasn't
sure himself
whether it was wanda or agatha but i
think there's a very good argument to be
made that it was accurate
they're everyone's saying that the pain
they're feeling feels like hopelessness
and loss
like how wanda feels about vision so
whether
that's being like um portaled or
whatever you want to call it
through um agonist being like i'm gonna
help control these people's minds but
i'm gonna give them the emotion that
wanda's feeling
because i don't think agnes has any
emotion towards anything really
as much as wand is having right now so i
don't know i still feel like it's still
mainly the vessel of
um wanda because everyone's like i feel
sad
it feels like heartbrokenness loss and
so
that's why i think they might be working
to get like she's trying to get her on a
team like
i think uh maria is completely right
that
marina could be completely right that it
was um she's trying to make a coven
again
yeah also i love a good coven
love a good cover you all want to be in
our coven
the world would be better off with more
covens running things
just saying yes i'm just saying just
join my coven
do you think next episode is going to be
a flashback
seeing how it all started yeah i do i i
think uh you see this a lot in tv shows
jessica and i have watched a lot of tv
and you often see like tv season one uh
the penultimate episode they set up a
big reveal
in episode you know the second or third
to last episode
uh and then the second to last episode
they go back i think ozark did that one
of the seasons lost definitely did that
final season uh watchmen didn't do that
in the penultimate episode it was like
episode six
out of eight or nine where she takes the
uh
the drug that allows her the empathy
drug that connects her to her
grandfather
but yeah i think this next step it's
gonna be a flashback and then episode
nine will be
the president oh yeah it will be the
closing yeah it doesn't so we're gonna
get
why she was in that room with all the
drawers in the next episode
yeah and i think we'll see flashback to
sokovia with the mind stone i think
that's all gonna be part of episode
eight
yeah absolutely all right we'll take one
more question and then we'll move on uh
here we go
why did she kill sparky
oh i don't want this to be the last
question
no this is perfect i know isn't that sad
isn't that horrible so yeah we talked
about this a little bit
i really think sparky was just digging
in the wrong spot
and i think sparky was eating some of
that uh creepy
haunted plant that she has in her garden
and
and that she didn't want sparky you know
unearthing literally
unearthing that uh secret
drug that she has been putting wanda on
truly
honey um asking the question watch
the old episode of sesame street where
big bird goes over
death it is it'll take out everything
you need
such a good sex that's how my mom taught
me she was like
and she showed me the episode of big
bird recognizing that people go on in
life
um the child voice of that coming
through my ears almost made me cry
i was like well it's the it's what we
all felt when she goes
and i killed sparky like it's not
funny at all but i was like oh saucy
i was like look at her she's okay with
admitting it now
i know and so i came at it with that but
when this person just asked that
question i was like oh my god it is a
dog
i forgot and i'm so sorry i was so on
the villain side that i was like it
doesn't matter
uh off screen brandon says we have one
little message here at the end
i look forward to these stereo podcasts
i don't sleep until i i hear
your voices and even if i do sleep it's
very little because i look forward to
this podcast
thank you guys so much for doing you
guys are great keep up the great work
i thank you thank you
yeah we we don't sleep for you you get
to sleep
we stay awake for you we're here for you
we are here for you guys
and thank you so much for all your
questions a lot a lot of great questions
i'm gonna jump on the uh uh all of our
next one division videos i got my work
cut out for me
this weekend and week uh but it's been
such a pleasure chatting more about this
with you jessica
and everybody listening to us on stereo
again if you missed the live version of
this you can
join us on stereo every friday morning
we start recording our inside marvel
taping
at eight a.m and then this uh bonus
segment continues after that
uh and yeah this is an exciting time to
be a one division fan there's still a
lot of directions it can go
uh follow me eddie avas follow jessica
lulu underscore clemens on twitter
uh she's got some great hot takes on
this every late thursday night when this
episode dropped
i love to see like what did jessica say
about this panic attack
when it wasn't loading i was like i'm
losing my mind jay washington if you
guys don't follow him go follow him he's
very funny comedian nerd
and he was he was in the span of 18
minutes he posted like 30
times and he was like he was like let me
in that server room i'm going to blow
into it like a nintendo cartridge
i was like you stop so
funny i was i was dying i was like he is
more upset than i
am it was so funny
no i try to i try not to spoil anything
if anybody in the comments spoils things
that's not on me and i will probably
talk to them not about
spoiling i'll just talk to him about it
because i want to talk to someone about
it
but um it's mainly my reaction of like i
can't handle it
i can't take this i'm losing my mind
well that's why we do these shows
uh so that we can congratulate peace
together
and if yeah if you want to support this
channel the best way to do it is to
check out one of our great merch options
at newarkstersmerch.com i'm i'm wearing
our unusual couple
shirt but the next best way to do that
is to support us directly on patreon
um patreon.com new rockstars and by
doing that you will get access to our
amazing discord community
that's where like moment by moment some
great wanna vision theories and clues
are being discovered there's uh
there's all kinds of great uh chatter uh
to check out so
yeah um and then listen to us on monday
wednesday and friday
on stereo stereo dot com slash new
rockstars it's a free app
uh we love everyone who has been
listening wow we had over 2 100 of you
listening to this
this episode it's so insane you guys are
lovely
um and we will see you all
next time everyone take care uh bye-bye
[Music]
you